votre fille a coulé mini sur le musée d'
Italie c'est avec le
billet Montecito et féminin judicieusement trouvé le long des
planètes avec mes propres peurs invisibles vous
devez descendre le multi vitamucil qui
investit à New York n'est pas seulement par Ally
Condie de la pista don '  Je ne vends pas le
super cercle américain pour vivre s'inscrire merci l'
une des plus grandes choses que j'ai remarquées
est que je n'ai vécu qu'à une époque où les
gens comprennent mal les musulmans où les
musulmans sont en quelque sorte perçus comme l'
ennemi, nous sommes constamment stéréotypés comme
étant les terroristes et  d'une certaine manière, je n'ai
été que je n'ai vu qu'une époque où nous
étions sur la défensive, vous savez, qui
essayaient constamment de dire non, nous sommes
américains ou serions normaux, nous sommes de bonnes
personnes,
vous savez où la religion de la justice où la
religion  de la paix la montée de Donald
Trump ouais et ses remarques haineuses et
toutes les choses qu'il dit oh mec
c'est une boîte de Pandore il est vraiment
dangereux je pense que je veux dire simplement il est
vraiment dangereux ce que vous voyez aussi maintenant
est très fort  corrélation des
crimes haineux contre les musulmans également
perpétrés par les partisans de Trump, alors peut-être que
Donald Trump pourrait nécessairement dire qu'il
tolère cela, mais il suscite ce genre
de haine
qu'il suscite ce genre de violence
quand il commence à créer ce récit
selon lequel c'est l'islam contre les États-
Unis  ou l'Islam contre l'Occident qui
ne valide que des groupes comme les
méthodologies d'Isis et leurs mentalités
parce qu'Isis ne me représente pas mais
ce qu'Isis essaie de dire, c'est que l'Amérique
de l'Amérique est un Devlin et que l'Occident est
le diable mais pour moi en tant que musulman pour tant
de  Musulmans, nous ne le voyons pas de cette façon
voyez-vous que vous avez été blessé en
quelque sorte je veux dire par Donald Trump savez par une
sorte de Hillary Clinton je souhaite juste
qu'on parle de nous d'un
point de vue moral en disant que c'est mal
ces gens  font partie de ce pays
font partie de ce pays depuis
sa fondation et puis ont en quelque sorte pris fin que
vous savez ne jamais ajouter cette mise en garde concernant
notre participation dans ce pays  étant
nous uniquement dans l'intérêt de la sécurité nationale
quelle est votre plus grande peur si Donald Trump
gagne euh ma plus grande peur n'est pas qu'il
expulse les musulmans je ne pense pas que cela
arrivera mais ma plus grande peur est quel genre
de haine va-t-il inspirer quel genre de
haine  va-t-il légitimer